[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk i'm arvin calzicci a content
developer and instructor with the
wolfram u team and today i have here
with me devendra kavadiya who's going to
tell us about the differential equations
mooc that he's been working on for quite
some time now devendra
right so um
differential equation is my kind of
topic that's what i've worked on at
wolfram since 2004 really and
i'm really pleased that at long last we
have
the mooc
the interactive course motors ready to
go
very soon and
so i think it's a good time to tell
people why we're doing it what the
background is
what it's like
inside the course and
where the future lies but uh as the name
says we are we are called gold from you
and the goal is one day to be
a provider for people who want to get a
self-contained
degree at home
this one off
free of cost and
you know where they can actually learn
things at the right pace with the right
kind of help so perhaps i should just go
ahead and tell you a little bit about
the background which i'm sure
you and other people know a bit about
but
basically we
began producing the first course from
work from you
around
2018 and then we had the calculus course
going out the characters courses for
high school students
for the ap exam ap calculus exam and
naturally that's a very uh important
thing so
we were surprised how popular it was um
and even today we get several thousand
people coming to the course every one
they get letters from nigeria remote in
nigeria uh from people who didn't have
the power but they managed to get a
computer for their you know uh for doing
the course i could
email from people in the far away
himalayas saying you know they could
actually learn calculus for the first
time because of this course so that's
very heartening very encouraging that
you know i can i've done all this work
so now that's 2018 then 2020 uh
i did a linear algebra course and uh
linear algebra is of course very
fundamental to data science and quantum
mechanics and things like that but uh
honestly i thought the calculus course
was a little too difficult
i had difficulty some of it myself you
know so if it's difficult for me it must
be even harder for students so the
linear algebra course is very nice and
simple but it talks about things which
people like to think about things like
quantum entanglement uh the work of
roger penrose people that who thought
deeply about these things so on the one
hand it's very easy on the hands very
applied and interesting yeah it's
fantastic to cover that sort of thing in
a linear algebra course like that yes
usually it's so you know it's just
here's a matrix here is how you do row
reduction it's just they only cover
these basic things and they don't tell
you what this stuff is actually useful
for but like you said is at the heart of
a lot of data science at the art of
quantum mechanics it's very important
and it's really good to convey that
early on to people so they know what
they're you know why they're learning
this stuff yes and we show things like
you know uh how do you compress an image
in uh the word from language and you
show the matrix and how
you can collapse it down to let's say
forty percent original image and so i
learned a lot i didn't know all the
stuff when i was student linear algebra
was chalk and talk
and today it's a different game so
to be honest i have evolved as well so
so uh the plan now is that we want this
new interactive course on differential
equations to come out
very soon and
then the point is that
we want people to leverage their
knowledge of calculus and linear but the
two things which you need to study
differential equations if you have those
two you're ready to go but people might
be different they might say well i'll
learn it as i go along so you might want
to combine the three and actually uh you
know do a kind of hybrid learning for uh
this area right and for folks who
haven't taken a wolf from you course
before when you say it's an interactive
course what does that mean that means
that you go to the website and
you actually
just start off the course
and go at any pace you like you can try
things out
in the web itself using the cloud
notebook
you can check things you can scroll back
you can look at the text if you're more
like a text reader you might have the
lesson open next to you which is
possible and then just read that so
interactor means that you're all the
time trying things yourself going at
your own pace learning going back and
it's much like being in a classroom uh
and i would say even better
okay so what i'm hearing is you have a
scratch notebook where you can kind of
work on problems while you're while
you're watching a video yes yes and in
addition to the video you also have a
kind of more lengthy text available that
you can reference yes we have all this
stuff available in one place while
you're learning exactly so
it works really well because
you can copy and paste things very
easily into the text thing so i think
that uh
people find that easy because they can
try things again they can manipulate
their inputs
check what happened they change things
and basically learning takes place at a
much deeper level than you would learn
on your own
so
so that's i guess the background to
the course and uh
the next point is to talk about
why we are doing it so
we really want to give an introduction
differential equation now this is to me
one of the most important branches of
mathematics and in fact
it's kind of relevant today because uh
differential equations uh began
after isaac newton but you know in 1760
uh
daniel bernoulli actually
modeled
the
the kind of the behavior of the
population dynamics if people were to be
inoculated with a small box vaccine and
at that time the average life expectancy
was 26 years seven months
and uh the question was should we
inoculate them or not and there were
three groups there was uh
bernoulli you said like pfizer and
modern now said go ahead inoculate uh
and he had data to back him up uh there
was dalenburg another famous man who
said you know
like the fda we need more data hold on
and then there were of course people who
opposed and said what a foolish idea and
what you might today call
the anti-vaxxers so the drama played out
that time but uh bernoulli emphasized
that differential equations uh are an
important tool for public health
physicians whether he was right wrong
was not clear to him as well but i think
when people learn differential equations
they learn to model the real world they
represent our best chance of modeling
the real world and i think that's why
you're doing the course and uh
so just to make it a little clear what
it is all about so we cover od that
means ordinary differential equation
what a mouthful uh and the single hero
of this course is d solve that's the
function in mathematica that actually
does all the
differential equations solving
i've worked on for a lot it's a super
function you can you can teach a class
on it you can write a book about it you
can write several books about and people
have
so
i think if you come to this course you
will have acquired an important skill
it's difficult but i think you can do it
yeah so yeah yeah i've used desolve
plenty of times myself you know my
background isn't physics so i've had to
use it quite a bit i know you're saying
differential equations are important for
all kinds of modeling so you mentioned
uh disease spread modeling but it's also
in economics and chemistry biology
physics i mean there's there's basically
nowhere you can go in the sciences or
any sort of modeling that doesn't have
differential equations so
invaluable tool here yes and i i i think
that therefore i say that the course was
for everyone in a way the economists
understand the french equivalent better
than anyone the black shows model which
on the one hand is used a lot in finance
and some people might even blame that
kind of model for the frequent financial
crisis that we have so differential
equations can make or break things it's
not really that i think it's the human
element the decisions we make which go
against us or for us so but thank you
for the support for this area which i
think is really important to have
language
so um i think having spoken a bit about
the goals maybe i should show you a
little bit about what's really inside
the course and i'll talk about
the heart of the course over here is
a
set of 31 video lessons and these video
lessons are you know the place where you
can learn the topic in great detail so i
think that
each of the differential equations
lessons will cover particular
area of subjects so the first lesson is
always what is x or y or z this one says
what is a differential equation so let
me just play a little bit and show you
what the lesson looks like
and so we begin with
you know what differential equation we
talk about differential equations
applications we then go on to you know
other things like
different differential equations we talk
a bit about history
then we go on to
why the important modern world and then
you go on to why study them
and then
well i guess the next question what the
course is about
who's this course for is it for me and
then the summary of the course but i
think that
if you actually go to course you will
understand that
this is an important tool for everyone
and
the course also has got exercises
quizzes
even a final exam
and when you come out of it you will
actually have learned a lot of uh about
the subject in a very informal
instructive way
okay so so you have multiple quizzes
there and a final exam that students can
take and what happens when they take
these are these like created by a person
are they
what happens with those right so at the
moment uh
we they auto grade so as you try them
out you get the grade and if you want to
try them out again that's fine you can
just try them again nothing happens so
the quizzes are actually very informal
and they're meant to actually make you
feel good about yourself that you
actually understood the subject the
exercises are completely solved i think
it's kind of a little unfair to make
students uh you know
solve things on their own so we do give
complete solutions and i hope that helps
people as well
so
i think that the course is very much
self-contained
so that's about the content and of
course the question is what do i get out
of it
and
so i'd like to talk a little bit about
certification
so this course has uh two little
certification
and uh basically you can either
say okay i want to complete the course
and get a level zero certificate which
means that
i've done the course i understand it but
i'm not really going to the final if you
like and the final is hard
for some people
and then on the other hand you might say
no i really do need the
final as well so let me do that
so uh
i think that's the plan that we have
to the certification and you see over
here that
the certificate has got the name
jules henry pankari on it
i'm not sure i know about him but
ponkari was one of the most famous
mathematicians he i would say he
even anticipated einstein and he was the
one of the last great
universalists the people you know
everything and i would hope that someone
attends this course will actually
you know become another poncare someday
that's my dream for them
and
the problem is this the problem is that
people
are kind of
scared of mathematics so you might ask
um can i get help
and to do that we actually have a study
group on differential equations planned
for
november 2021 where people can come and
study uh this subject in a very guided
manner
right and study groups for people who
aren't familiar with those basically
every day for depends on the course but
two to three weeks is typical we'll see
how long this one will be yes um yeah so
we just finished all the planning it's
gonna be three weeks okay uh 31 lessons
two lessons a day uh with an instructor
every day and uh i say at this point
that the i've done the earlier courses
myself but i thought it's time for
someone else to try and do one so luke
titus is instructor uh he's worked very
hard he worked 16 hours on labor day
weekend he really labored on labor
weekend
and
i think that luke is a fantastic
instructor he'll be around uh i'll come
in once a week and see
what they call me the expert i'm really
learning as much as anyone else but i'll
come in once a week to make sure things
are going okay so i think that uh the
studies group should be a great place to
learn about
this course we've certainly gotten a lot
of good feedback from study group
participants so far because they like to
come in it's it's a nice pace every day
there's an hour in this case perhaps two
hours of of instruction from some
certified instructor there are exercises
that go along with these things there
are quizzes there are poll questions to
kind of check your understanding as you
go so this is kind of a nice way where
you know you might want to do the mooc
and you might also want to come to the
study group and have kind of a more
directed learning experience sure and
i've done one of myself it's pretty
exhausting because the students are very
very demanding
they they find lots of mistakes which i
would never find myself
and
i have really honestly sweated out to
you know get satisfy them but that's
great because then people are actually
thinking they are learning the subject
so i think the way to do this is to
enroll for study group and learn about
the subject because that's the most
efficient way to do it
and
of course
we are talking about differential
equation now but my mind is not there
i'm thinking about the next year
and next year we got even better things
planned so
for the next year i've got two courses
in mind
uh there's a course on
elementary algebra like middle school
algebra
at the low end of and then there's a
multi-variable calculus course at the
other end
and i think that
to have the algebra course is important
i taught high school algebra a long time
ago my students are now directors one of
them is an architect in chicago and she
wrote to me saying that had it not been
for your mathematics teaching i would
not be here so when i walk by buildings
i know i did maybe an impact on society
so um algebra is important uh what you
see was the quadratic formula perhaps
the most uh
important formula in algebra this stuff
beyond that nothing is important that so
i think that uh
algebra is going to be a great course
and of course you are been uh going to
be doing it yes so how's that going it's
going pretty well we're making progress
on it we're uh recording lessons writing
scripts you know updating the
mathematics itself yeah uh at least the
presentation of the mathematics we we
may not be discovering any new math
exactly but i think this will be a
really great foundation for people who
are coming in and want to learn some
math you know maybe when they're done
with this they can move on to linear
algebra and calculus and eventually even
this multivariable calculus course that
you're talking about right and the
multiple calculus course actually is
pretty difficult but very beautiful
we've got a gallery of graphics which
will please anyone in the world and uh
george green green's theorem he actually
was a miller he was a baker and you know
he worked in a mill by day and by night
he'd go up to the top of a star and do
mathematics
uh he's a great inspiration for me so
you learn about the work of george green
all kinds of stuff but my feelings that
when we have finished all these five
courses anyone who does them all
deserves an applause so we plan to give
a certificate in mathematics to those
who actually complete all the five
courses so this is a dream the dream is
do one course this year do two more next
year and then we can say okay now we
have a full suite of mathematics courses
and
to make that happen of course we've got
so many teams there's uh word from you
there's
document quality assurance there's our
excellent video team everyone does their
bit to make things fly you know so i
thank them all for yeah this is a real
collaboration each one of these courses
is the work of a lot of people coming
together
yes so i think that
i just want to send message that if you
want to learn mathematics vol from you
is now the place to do it and keep an
eye out we've got lots of stuff coming
yeah well great thank you very much for
telling us about you know this uh course
that's in the works hopefully november
2021 that's when the study group is and
hopefully the mooc will come out around
that i'm sure so we should be just fine
too i mean to finish up and yes for sure
okay and then we have these two new
courses introduction to elementary
algebra and introduction to
multi-variable calculus that will be
coming out next year if all things go
well i think they should be ready next
year for sure right thank you very much
for the encouragement and
i mean it's nice to talk and have a
chance to
let people know what we're doing
thanks once again to vendra for telling
us about uh all these interesting
courses that are coming up and the
upcoming study group as well thank you
i've been it's a pleasure to talk with
you
and you know talk about my passion with
mathematics courses
yes it's infectious i look forward to
working with you more on the algebra
course thank you all right that was
devendra who is our manager for calculus
and algebra here at wolfram research so
stay tuned for more upcoming tech talks
and remember we do have in november 2021
this differential equation study group
coming up so if you're interested in
learning about differential equations
the study group is a great way to do
that so please sign up and we'll have
plenty more tech talks coming your way
on a variety of subjects see you next
time